good morning how are you all doing
hands up anyone who's got a party
hangover that's great we should
celebrate software and coding and
development and all being together like
this and I'm gonna talk to you now for
an hour or so about architecture the
stuff that's hard to change this is me
Dylan bTW I'm CTO at skills matter in
London I'm a Microsoft MVP with the
visual studio and developer tools
program
I run the dotnet user group in London I
created a programming language called
Rockstar so that everyone can be
Rockstar developers and I have some
Rockstar swag to give away which I don't
want to take home so come and grab some
at the end and about five or six years
ago the company I was working for hired
some consultants to restructure things
and one of them had a long series of
interviews with me and said oh we think
you'd be better suited as the system's
architect and so I get this email dear
Dylan this is to confirm your change of
job role the systems architect you are
now responsible for architecture
architecting doing architect stuff
systems architecture and architecting
systems congratulations and so I go back
to my desk and I sit down and I go hey
I'm an architect now doesn't feel any
different visual studio still doesn't
load very fast you know and that started
me on this this journey of you know it's
like if I'm gonna do this job I want to
do this job well so I want to understand
what is architecture actually all about
what does it look like when you do it
well what's the role of an architect on
a good team and I sort of started off by
digging a little bit into the words we
use cuz we have all these words we use
in software that we kind of steal from
elsewhere like you know we talked about
pythons and mice and people are like
yeah I - I have a Python in my house I
feed it my sis like no no Python mice
are different and we have buses and we
have pipelines and we talked about
launching and crashing and you know
these are all English words which means
something else and we've taken them and
gone no no no no no we're gonna use them
to mean a completely different thing and
this you know language can be a really
powerful way of understanding the
approach people have to problems there
is some controversy in the world so so
put your hand up if you're a developer
you call
salford developer keep your hand up if
you call yourself a hacker coder
architect front-end back-end engineer
the word engineer is this controversial
term we have we talk about software
engineering now there are some countries
in the world where you are not allowed
to do that in Canada you are not allowed
to be an engineer unless you have an
engineering license from the Canadian
government in New Zealand you can be an
engineer if you have a degree in
software engineering but not if you have
a degree in software development or
computer science you have to have
engineer in your degree and I live in
the UK and a couple weeks ago the cable
TV and my house went out and they sent
an engineer to fix it as I I do not
think that this person has an
engineering degree you know but we have
these ideas about architecture and
engineering and you know my very first
job years ago I worked for Arab who are
a big construction company and they have
architects and they have engineers and I
sort of started digging a little bit
into where these roles come from and the
distinction that kind of makes sense to
me let's think about construction for a
minute we have these two things here the
little barbecue on the left that's a
hack like that probably the person who
designed that built it by themselves
or they got a couple of friends and
helped with them the thing on the right
is the Brooklyn Bridge the guy who
designed the Brooklyn Bridge did not
build it by himself now and this I think
is an interesting distinction
you know architecture maybe is the point
where you're involved in designing
software that you're not actually gonna
write like you're coming up with the
designs and the interfaces and the
structures but you're not gonna be the
person actually writing the code and in
building architecture we have these
amazing examples that we celebrate and
people travel all over the world to go
and looks at look at these kinds of
things and in software architecture we
kind of were a little bit behind the
curve on that what was the last time you
showed someone a code base and when look
at this it's absolutely beautiful now
come and look at it from this side here
take a picture
you know maybe architecture and software
is not quite the same as what the rest
of the world thinks of architecture is
and it's only software and buildings
that have architects they're on
aeroplanes Architects there aren't
racing-car architects or plumbing
architects you know
now let's dig a little bit deeper
because the first person to use the term
software engineering was this lady
anybody know who this is
you should she's awesome Margaret
Hamilton she was the lead engineer on
the guidance systems for Apollo 11 and
she was the first person to talk about
software engineering and what she called
taking a systems view of how software
works with all of the other components
in a system which in this case was the
system that took Neil Armstrong and Buzz
Aldrin and landed them on the moon she
was the first person to talk about
software as an engineering discipline
it's not something you do after the site
by yourself it's something that has to
fit in with all of the other processes
and machinery and systems that are
happening to make this this project work
the first person to use the term
architecture about computer systems was
Fred Brooks he wrote the mythical
man-month with from sure some of you
have read very very influential engineer
and scientist and way back in the 1960s
1962 he was working on a system for IBM
called stretch and in the prelude to
that he has this quote computer
architecture like other architecture is
the art of determining the needs of the
user of a structure and then designing
to meet those needs as effectively as
possible within economic and
technological constraints first time the
word architecture was applied to
computer systems now back in the 60s and
70s and 80s computer architecture almost
always meant hardware because hardware
was the stuff which was expensive to
change if you decided to change the way
a piece of code worked you just wrote
some new code and you shipped it and you
were fine but there are fundamental
decisions one of the decisions that Fred
Brooks made on the IBM stretch project
was to use eight bits in a byte instead
of six and basically you can trace
almost every computer since then the
8-bit byte convention that all of us use
you can trace back to this decision now
you imagine changing that decision
halfway through building a computer
system it's like alright that's it throw
away the processors throw away the
motherboards throw away the busses throw
away the factories that we've built to
create the motherboards and processors
we got to start the whole thing all over
again
expensive to change software was always
cheap as
a percentage of the whole cost of
building a system two things happened
around the 1990s which started changing
the way we think about this the first of
them was business software went
mainstream companies who had you know
never ever had computers before suddenly
they had computers and they were getting
people to build software for them in
visual basic and you know little
companies florists and little hotels and
you know carwash places were hiring
somebody to write them a little piece of
software and they set it up and run it
and it would be great and they could
print your invoices and stuff and then a
couple of weeks later they'd be like oh
it doesn't do this thing we need we need
to change it how much
and suddenly the cost of making changes
to a software system became a
significant proportion of the investment
for a lot of these businesses and so we
started thinking what is it gonna cost
to change software we've already created
the other thing that happened was the
world wide web up until this point
pretty much all software ran on one
computer and if it had any output at all
it was a screen or a printer we didn't
really do email we certainly didn't do
apps and api's and uploading and stuff
the world wide web came along and
suddenly instead of building software
that would run on one beige box in an
office we're building stuff that runs on
thousands of machines all over the world
clients and servers and gateways and all
these components and there are companies
now for whom the cost of changing
software is almost their entire
operating budget you know they have a
couple of janitors and some HR people
but almost the entire payroll is just
people who change code all day every day
and for those companies if those changes
are cheap they're profitable if those
changes are expensive they're in trouble
and so we kind of hone in on this idea
of architecture as being the stuff
that's hard to change because everything
else is just coding right the first kind
of formal treatment of software
architecture was this book Mary Sean
David garland it's published in 1995 and
one of the things I love about this is
they they called it an attempt to
formalize a substantial folklore of
system design they're all these people
all over the world having good ideas
about how to build bigger systems faster
systems
modular computer systems but no one had
ever kind of brought all is thinking
together and gone let's try and get some
some words on this so we can have
conversations about how to do all this
stuff better I want to dig into Fred
Brooks definition a little bit because I
like this and I want to break this down
into three things
so architecture determining the needs of
a user designing to meet those needs
within economic and technological
constraints now one of the big
revelations for me in you know my my
journey to becoming an architect was
realizing who the users were because we
build computer systems right and we
think that the user is the person on the
other end who's dragging and dropping
and filling in forms and all this kind
of stuff when you're an architect who
are your users they are the developers
on the team your job is to serve the
needs of the people who are gonna be
building and shipping the systems that
you're working on and it's not just the
people who are on your team today it is
the people who you are going to be
hiring next year or the people who are
gonna be working on your open-source
projects in three or four years time and
so your role is to think about how do I
serve people we haven't met yet building
software we haven't written yet to sell
things we haven't thought of yet to
customers that we haven't got yet and
make it more happy easy right we're
probably going to need a plan now plans
have had a bit of a rough time when it
comes to software engineering because of
this wonderful thing called the agile
manifesto which everybody jumped on and
read and when this is brilliant now not
a lot of people know this but renege
they got that the French philosopher was
actually an agile consultant on on the
side when he wasn't doing philosophy and
he's working with a client one day and
he says to them you know the agile
manifesto says that we should respond to
change instead of following a plan and
the pliant says oh that's brilliant we
haven't got a plan and they cut your
salary blah if you don't have a plan how
can you choose not to follow it
it's not a valid choice there is a
difference between saying this is our
plan but circumstances have changed the
plan is no longer accurate and just
going we haven't planned anything let's
just make it up as we go along and see
what happens what the authors of the
agile manifesto had observed time and
time again his team's deliberately doing
the wrong thing because that's what the
plan said and that was what they were
trying to address when they wrote this
we are uncovering better ways of
developing software through this work
we've come to value responding to change
over following a plan while there is
value in the items on the right we value
the items on the left more you need a
plan but the plan is not guaranteed to
be accurate the plan is a living
document you as an architect need to
have some idea what it is you're going
to be trying to do and how those things
fit together there is another detail in
the agile manifesto or one of the the
principles behind it that I just wanted
to bring up we follow these principles
the best architectures requirements and
designs emerge from self-organizing
teams now the point that they're trying
to make here if you have a team of
people who are working well together and
are coming up with their own way of
doing things step back and let it happen
do not hire people and go there you go
go over there and self organize and then
you come back in a month and you're like
where's the project and they're like we
self organized into the bar across the
street what do you want us to do now you
know um be prepared for this to happen
because high functioning teams will
click and they will start this positive
feedback loop but if your team come to
you and say we could use some help you
know we're not sure how to approach this
we don't know how to collaborate on this
you need a better answer as an architect
than just yet go and self organize it's
fine you need to give them the support
to allow these things to emerge let's
talk about constraints here are the
rules no new hires no JavaScript no open
source no microsoft no cookies this I
believe is the engineering principles of
the Oracle Corporation
we're not gonna work here this would
suck but everything you do there are
going to be constraints there are gonna
be things you just cannot do you know we
cannot yet beam solid objects around the
world if someone comes to you and goes
can we build a teleport thing for shrimp
you'll be like no that's not a thing
sometimes they gotta come to you and go
can we do high-definition like video
calls in real time without using wires
and for a long time you'll say no no no
no and then one day you'll be like
actually maybe yes for a long time
everybody believed that a touchscreen
phone was going to be a disaster because
all the touchscreens anyone had ever
seen were those plastic things in the
airport that don't work and they click
in the wrong place and there was a team
of people working at Apple who were
working on all these different things
different kinds of glass different kinds
of touchscreen displays multi-touch and
they were the people who everyone else
was going a touchscreen phone is
impossible the constraints are too big
and they weren't actually no now it's
possible now we can do it and they
launched the iPhone and within a year
everyone was going yeah of course
everyone wants a touchscreen phone you
know we'll do one will do on Google did
one Android did one all of these
different things converged sometimes as
an architect your job is to keep an eye
on everything that is happening so you
can come to the table and go the thing
we thought was impossible maybe now is
the time one of the things about this
job which is difficult is communicating
those constraints to the developers all
your developers they go to NDC and they
go back to work and go new shiny
JavaScript frameworks gonna solve all
our problems and you're the one who has
to say sorry we have to support Internet
Explorer that is one of the constraints
of what we're doing because this is a
business we have a big client they're
still using IE 9 or god help you IE 8 or
something and you're the one who has to
communicate those constraints and
explain to people yeah I know you want
to do it this way but that doesn't
actually align with the constraints of
the system that we're designing here so
there we go
determine user needs meet those needs
within economic and technological
constraints now actual doing software
architecture is really easy it's got to
do three things you got to make a
decision communicate it and then
reinforce it thank you very much bye-bye
now we'll do some more so making
decisions how do you choose someone
comes to you as the architect and says
we want to build a system that does this
we want to D cup alike a login system so
he can build different micro services
that use common authentication how can
we do that and your job is to come up
with a way of doing it before you can do
that you need to understand five things
first of all what have you got now a lot
of time in organizations and software
teams there will be two versions of the
truth there will be what people think
they have because they paid someone a
lot of money for a high performance
transaction processing system and there
will be what they actually have which is
a hundred thousand lines of Ruby that
doesn't work properly you know and you
need to understand these disparities now
the best way I found of doing this is to
look at the borders the boundaries
between the different systems you want
to understand the traffic that is
flowing between the components of these
systems don't worry too much about the
code don't worry about the spec and you
know when people tell you what something
does take it with a pinch of salt it's
useful but it might not be a hundred
percent accurate here is the simplest
possible systems diagram I can think of
now as an architect you don't care
whether that website is PHP or dotnet or
Perl or Ruby or whatever and the
internet there's someone else's problem
but this thing in the middle
HTTP how many questions can you ask
about that how many transactions does it
cope with is there HTTP on it
when does the certificate expire does it
cope with yet put post what if I put a
proxy in there how much of this stuff
can we cash are we using etags on the
traffic that flows across it just by
putting a network trace on that HTTP and
watching it for half an hour will tell
you more about how this website actually
works than any number of hours spent
reading the code and going oh this
module looks interesting oh it's never
been run we don't know why it's here you
know traffic is real traffic is is the
lifeblood of living systems you don't
care what anything was designed to do
your gene Kranz in Apollo 13 you care
what it can do you need to understand
the actual capabilities of the systems
not what was in the spec and sometimes
this will be disappointing like
our high performance authentication
system can only cope with six users a
minute sometimes it'll be pleasantly
surprising you'll dig into AWS and be
like there's a whole Redis cluster in
here that I didn't know we had this is
brilliant we can start using this to
speed up all kinds of things we can put
varnish in front of our web server and
boom instant acceleration and we can
start rewriting stuff you know there
will be pleasant surprises as well as
disappointments it's well worth taking
the time to do this of course some of
you are going well we're working on a
greenfield project here we don't have
anything there is no such thing as a
greenfield project because there are
always gonna be a couple of little
systems scattered around the landscape
maybe there's some sales data in an
Excel spreadsheet that you need to work
with and some of this you'll be able to
work with and some of it you won't for
complicated reasons there will be the
wreckage of the last attempt to build
the Greenfield system because somebody
has always tried this before and
there'll be some code kicking around
there will be politics there will be the
person who got fired for choosing to use
Microsoft sequel server and so now no
one will touch Microsoft sequel server
because the last person who did it got
fired and you know like now ok I'm
really glad we know that because now we
know how to approach those kinds of
conversations there will be the rabbit
hole the thing that looks really really
easy and you say to your team you just
just integrate Redis with nginx and they
come back three months later and they go
boss we really need some this is not
going how it said it would in the
documentation all of these things are
out there and only once you understand
them you know where they are can you
really make informed decisions about how
to approach what you're doing you know
what you've got what do you need
you got a most business stakeholders
they say yeah the website needs to be
fast website needs to be secure you say
brilliant thank you for the briefing you
go to your team hey boss wants it to be
fast the team go brilliant well build
our own HTTP accelerator I saw a
conference talk about it and you go back
two weeks later and the boss says is the
project finished yeah and you go no no
the team is working on an HTTP
accelerator it's really cool they're
using bitwise pattern matching on the
incoming network stream to get a top ten
of the the fastest web servers ever and
the boscoe's not that fast how fast turn
these into business conversations
because as the architect you're gonna be
the conduit between what does it mean in
tech and what does it mean in reality
how fast is a fast website 500
millisecond
response time from 90th percentile some
stakeholders will be that sounds
brilliant some will be what's the
percentile you set him down you got okay
what this means is if ten people are on
our website one of them is gonna have to
wait a little bit and I'll say how long
and you say I don't know one second five
seconds and now that yeah five seconds
is too long no no we don't want that so
you can turn this into a conversation
and they come back and go make it faster
and you say well that's gonna cost and
they say how else can we make it faster
and you say we could take off the
JavaScript that draws the banner adverts
and they go we can't do that and you're
like well you want it fast or cheap you
kind of both you know turn these into
business conversations they say it needs
to be secure how secure you know go
beyond just it needs to be secure what
is the threat model that you're worried
about here there's a great talk I saw
James mikans give here a couple years
ago where he was talking about basically
three different threat models which are
Russian botnets you're angry ex-partner
and Mossad and Russian botnets are going
to knock on the door for three seconds
and if they don't get in they're going
to move on to the next account so you
know they download these huge tables of
passwords from the Pirate Bay and that
kind of stuff that's one threat profile
the angry ex-partner this is a difficult
one because they probably have access to
the cellphone that belongs to the
account so two-factor authentication
might not work so think of mechanisms
for working around that Mossad are
already in your system just stop
worrying about it and enjoy your life
and don't piss them off what can you
build if you decide right we need to do
this this is what we're shipping how
dependably and reliably can you hit
those targets at your sprints or your
iterations or your stand-ups or whatever
cycle you're using to do this work and
this this one boils down to what I call
four p's people patterns packages
process who are the people on your team
and who are the people you can hire
which communities is your project
interesting to other people there you
can reach out to and get them involved
you know how easily what kind of skills
have you got your angular people f-sharp
people react people back in front and
understand all of these and align them
with the kind of work that you're doing
make technology choices based on who
you've got based what you can do who you
can hire patents are the kind of
conceptual building blocks of modern
software and some patent
fit very well with some people using
some languages and some don't I've been
doing a lot of work in Ruby on Rails
recently and rails is so tightly coupled
to the MVC pattern that we had a
10-minute conversation the other day
about something that they called a
service object and I was like what is
the service even sure how about that
talking about classes just you know
classes behavior and data and a thing
and rails is so coupled to it's a model
of view or a controller that something
that isn't one of these things has a
special name whereas in dotnet we start
with everything's a class and then
you're like oh yeah and if your class
does this then it's probably the
controller pattern understand the
relationship between the patterns and
the technology choices you're making
because that can make a huge difference
especially if you find yourself fighting
the own the language or the frameworks
opinions about the patterns you should
be working with packages all language is
now survived in a sort of ecosystem of
components and libraries and modules and
you need to encode a transparent PNG or
do some crypto or stream some video for
most languages you'll be able to find
someone who has already solved this
problem understand the breadth of the
ecosystem that you're choosing to work
with how easily can you get those
packages are they actively maintained
what happens if one of them goes away
how easy is it to fork and do your own
thing and process is just about
reproducibility it's about being able to
sit down on a Monday morning and say
we're gonna ship this by Friday and on
Friday most of the time you've done it
it's about how your people collaborate
together it's about how well you
understand the the pitfalls and the
capabilities of the systems that you're
working with what can you buy there is a
rule
Dillons law of software never use
PowerShell when you could use MasterCard
your team should be building the things
that you can sell the things or you know
the things you can give away the things
that create the value for your
organization you know don't create your
own cloud system Amazon have done that
unless you are trying to compete with
Amazon in the cloud infrastructure space
that is a waste of your time they solve
that problem you solve your problem look
at everything you're doing now there is
a point here there's a really
interesting conversation about using
Google Analytics because one of the
systems that I'm working on has its own
tracking and analytics engine and the
reason for that is that we are using
those analytics as part of the product
and someone said why don't you just use
Google Analytics and I said because we
don't want to rely on Google for
something we are actually providing to
our customers this is what we do we're
delivering it we own the value stream
for that for seeing how many people
clicked on an email yeah we have Google
Analytics for that that's fine there's
this sort of you know yin and yang
there's this balance here what can you
lose
raise your hand if there is a system in
your company that sends email keep your
hand raised if there are two systems
that send email three four five I once
did an audit we wanted to rebrand the
outgoing email to fit the new corporate
color scheme I found fifteen different
places in code where a developer had
written some code to create an email
message template to populate the HTML
and send it and the first person who did
this was definitely me because nothing
existed and I sat down went this the
second one was a developer who didn't
know that I'd already done the first one
the third one was somebody who went
we'll two people have done this already
so clearly that's how stuff works around
here the fourth one was an outsource and
you know I had to go and go look making
the emails purple is actually going to
be really complicated we've turned the
color of an email into a software
architecture problem because we have
this duplication so what we actually did
was in the process of turning it purple
we consolidated all of our email into an
outgoing relay service that applied the
branding at the Perimeter before it got
sent look for that kind of duplication
because there's gonna be opportunities
to make things easier streamline them
recover some technical debt just you
know improve the cost of changing those
things once you understand these five
things you got to decide what to do now
this is kind of the easy part because
once you've been through all those
motions you've had the conversations
you've talked to the teams you
understand the landscape you come to
things like NDC and you kind of keep up
with what's going on in the industry and
the community a solution will emerge
you'll have a couple of good ideas
you'll bounce them off some people on
your team you'll be like you know I
think we should do it this way then
comes the really fun part you have
decided what the software is going to
look like and in your head is this
beautiful crystalline structure of data
flowing through systems and interfaces
you know data structures and Landers and
server lists and cloud and you sit down
with the team like let me show you how
the software's gonna work and you draw
them the diagram and they look at it and
they go what is that is that Java I'll
talk about the problem with diagrams now
in construction engineering you hire
someone to build you a building they
will start by making some drawings and
you'll look at the drawings and you'll
be like alright I'm sure you know what
you're doing and they'll give you some
more drawings and they will produce
drawings of end elevations side
elevations plan views schematics but
sooner or later they will come up with
artist's impressions visualizations and
you'll look at that and you go okay I
can see where we're going with this and
I'll come up with slightly higher
fidelity versions and you'll think okay
and then they will build the building
and you will go it's exactly what I
thought it was gonna be and you can look
at it and you can look at the drawing
look at the building and go yeah did it
nailed it that's exactly what I expected
now we grow up surrounded by drawings
one of the earliest earliest things that
we learn to do as children is draw to
communicate by making marks on pieces of
paper and your parents stick them on the
fridge and hope that you get better at
heart before it gets embarrassing you
know and we get good at reading we have
picture books as kids with with pictures
and we match the pictures to the words
so we are visual creatures who grew up
surrounded by diagrams and drawings and
photographs and illustrations that we
kind of intuitively know how to read and
get meaning from unfortunately in
software this is not necessarily true
here is a software architecture diagram
who wants to go and build this for me
now this is this is a formal notation
this is a diagram drawn using a notation
you can learn in school I'd studied this
at university this is the yordan de
março notation for software engineering
who can tell me what the things on this
diagram are anybody nobody
no it's not the slashes are the wrong
way around the thing on the right
well for starters let's add a key for
you know people who might have forgotten
a little bit of your than DeMarco since
they were in school so there we go
there's the key to the Orden demarco
notation so the thing that the top-right
is not a regular expression it's a
database or a file system we don't know
which but it's a database or a file
system and that the oval things there
are functions so now you can look at
this and you can be like okay so we've
got some you know these two things that
have got data in them and then they're
going through these two ovals and then
there's this bottom right thing what is
that okay that's input/output and for
some reason it's called mandrill and
Hann I think I might know what mandrel
is because I remember reading about it
in the MailChimp documentation so maybe
it's that and this thing with the
backslash backslash that maybe that's a
Windows file share it's got a dollar on
the end you know could be let's start
decorating this with some more detail so
first of all internal code names let's
just put quotes around them to say don't
bother googling this you ain't gonna
find anything Excelsior is a sequel
server full of customer details why is
it called excelsior cuz the person who
built it got it out of Excel I don't
care naming is hard
mercutio what is it it's a dotnet
service that populates email templates
so Norman is a dotnet app that sends
emails why Norman Mailer okay thanks
Steve
really appreciate that this thing over
here JK 6 GB 87 that is the Dell asset
tag of the server where the marketing
department keep all their email
templates all these things are real by
the way these are actual bits of
software that I've worked on and
mandrill is the smtp relay service for
MailChimp which is an email platform so
now we're kind of getting like we're
still not sure but you could sit down
and go okay I think I understand the
kind of people we're gonna need to build
this system we're still restricted by
the fact we're using the or DeMarko
notation because we got it out of a book
and that means the only things we can
conceptualize our databases functions
data flows in for outputs scrapped it
let's come up with our own notation
nobody can read it anyway we're gonna
have to include a key boom now we're
getting somewhere
we've got some clipart and we've got
some Microsoft Office templates and we
got some stuff we found on Google we've
got this this red line here with the
boxes on it which I crypt out of the
rabbit and queue documentation
so now we can be like okay this is cool
we got excelsior that what is the green
line here that's a do dotnet okay this
makes sense
we got Mercutio what's the little gear
wheel okay those are Windows services
that blue thing there that's an SMB file
share okay and we're starting to think
okay I understand now like you can look
at this diagram see what kind of things
are gonna have to do to deliver it let's
go even further let's annotate the
traffic boundaries a deonette ok windows
authentication now we know how to plug
these things into each other this
Windows file share we're using for text
and HTML this rabbitmq okay that's cloud
AMQP brilliant we know how to work with
that SMTP port 993 TLS enabled that's
why I can't send any email I'm using the
wrong port and I don't have the
certificate now we have enough
information here to actually have a
meaningful conversation how are we going
to build this how long is it gonna take
how many instances do we need to
provision to run it the one on the left
looks like the ones in the textbooks it
is neat and it is elegant and it looks
like the work of a professional
and the people reading it go I'm not
gonna ask about that because I don't
want to look stupid the one on the right
is starting to look like a bit of a mess
but it's a mess which has useful
information in it and you can actually
use to have a conversation one of the
big challenges that I find in all kinds
of software development is the examples
in the books and the tutorials and the
conferences are always tiny no one ever
shows you how messy the stuff gets when
you do it for real this is one part of a
systems architecture diagram that I
built as part of a outsource and
collaboration project about five years
ago and this you know is literally
broken down there's a key on here like I
said this is all the different kinds of
traffic there's even a color code in
there for some hideous VB cursor based
library we knew that existed the network
traffic made no sense but we knew it had
Visual Basic on one end and sequel
server on the other we could never make
any any sense of it so we capture on
there look this thing's here it's
important but abandoned hope you're
never gonna find out how this thing
works
and just stick you know arbitrary
notations like there's a comment on here
database Inc every five minutes updates
user names and passwords you can do it
on demand by pressing the big red button
put that kind of it because this is
something people are like alright it's
already messy what if we scribble on it
let's start making notes and annotating
and moving things around and stuff and
this is what diagrams look like when you
actually try and convey reality instead
of
make things that look good like they did
in the engineering textbooks final note
about diagrams here are two software
architecture diagrams one of these is
the hexagonal architecture which one
I'll give you a clue it's not the one
with the hexagons on it a lot of the
time there will be you know words like
like hexagonal architecture and tear
ports and adapters layered interfaces
that kind of if you've heard the
expression hexagonal architecture and
you look at these diagrams you will
logically assume that the one with the
hexagons is hexagonal architecture now
we use the name hexagonal architecture
because the first version of the paper
about ports and adapters used hexagons
and the diagrams in the name kind of
stuck it's got nothing to do with
hexagons there aren't necessarily six of
anything in a hexagonal architecture
it's just a name we got the thing on the
left with the data ports and the
adapters in the fast doors that's
hexagonal thing on the right is a
honeycomb with clipart pasted into it
it's nothing to do with software I made
it up never be afraid to ask never be
afraid to say hi I'm sorry I'm still not
clear can you just run through what that
thing on the diagram is one more time
what is this line here do what are these
things the yellow thing is that a sequel
server database you know by having these
kinds of conversations one it makes it
okay for the other people in the room to
be like yeah I don't understand either
can we do that again - it gives the
architect the context of like okay next
I might present something these are the
things I want to cover in advance so
that we can cut straight to what are we
going to do and how we're going to build
it it's all about reinforcing decisions
so you've come up with your design you
understand the constraints you know what
it is that you're trying to deliver now
you want to help the team build the
right thing I did initially call this
enforcing decisions but I kind of didn't
like the kind of you know the architect
as police kind of deal you want to
support your team in the work that
they're doing and this boils down at two
different kinds of things what we call
validation and verification validation
are we building the right thing this is
hard because what you can do is come
back in ten years and see whether this
company's still in business and the
software worked there isn't really a
shortcut for this but verification are
we building the thing right is the thing
we're creating
does it match and reflect the ideas and
designs and structures that we've talked
about now with construction architecture
you can take your diagram and you can
take your building and you can look at
them side-by-side and you can go yeah
that looks right to me and there are
other dimensions to it engineering
stress diagrams and load-bearing things
and stuff but this technique we
developed as kids of looking at a
drawing and telling whether it looks
like real life or not that holds us in
good stead so let's do the same thing
with some software here's our diagram
right teams built the code it's done
it's shipped we want to have a look at
it and see if it looks like the diagram
how do we look at the software I know
Microsoft Azure has a dashboard let's
look at that it was very pretty
but it doesn't really look like the
diagram maybe teamcity can show us
what's going on they're still pretty but
it doesn't really help us and these red
bits might be bad I know we'll look at
the code now I'm just not seeing that
the relationship here how can you tell
whether the software that has been built
matches the design the architecture the
concepts and the structures and things
now when I first started at doing this I
made a classic mistake which is I did
I'll do all the code reviews so all the
teams can build what they want and then
as the architect I'll review the code
I'll read it I'll make sure that it's
right this really really sucked in it
was horrible and I do not recommend you
ever try it one you'll burn out you'll
have days when you're still at work at 7
o'clock at 8 o'clock at night and you're
like are those 15 pull requests still to
review but if I don't review these
nobody can do any work tomorrow and so
you just kind of get sloppy and you're
just like yeah that kind of looks right
I don't know and the other thing is that
restricts the ability of your teams to
do stuff that you don't understand and
you get this I reviewed your see SHOP
code and I still don't know what it does
and your lead engineer says dude my
team's using Scala
the other problem with reviewing the
code is have a look at this code here
now we've had a meeting about the
architecture and the design and we've
said we're gonna use a repository
pattern with an identity map and
everyone has gone on repository identity
map we understand mr. architect thank
you very much and then they give you
this code what can you tell from this
code you can tell that the developers
knew that the word repository and the
identity map were important and they
should use these names the names don't
tell you what the code does they just
tell you what somebody called it reading
code and trying to distill what it does
on a good team
who used name inconsistently and who
kind of understand the relationship
between patterns and classes and naming
and stuff it can work but it could also
be a bit of a minefield it's like
wandering through a city at night and
going who luxury hotel that looks pretty
good and then you wake up in the morning
and you're like okay maybe following the
labels was not the best way of
understanding what we were doing here so
what can we do to kind of gently guide
our teams down the correct path create a
pit of success that will help them come
up with the right kind of implementation
one of the most powerful things you can
do is to exploit something called
Conway's law teams that build systems
the system they build will end up
matching the communication and
organization structures of the teams who
built it so if you have software which
is split into components you want
tight-knit teams building a component
and another tight-knit team building
another component and another team
building another component and align
them with the technology choices bunch
of front end people ok you to the front
end this sounds obvious but there's
places that get this wrong front end
team you're over there angular react
JavaScript whatever you want to do
that's your bit you've over here you're
doing F sharp and you know calculations
and back-end and price quoting all this
kind of stuff you can even exploit
geography to make this happen you know
say all right well we've got an angular
team over here in London we've got a F
sharp team over in Belarus where we've
outsourced a lot of the heavy lifting
and the processing and then our Android
team is going to be based down in Porto
what you get here is the boundaries
between these things will naturally
emerge because it's really really
cheaper to collaborate and it's really
really expend
to change something collaborating with a
team in another time zone so you get the
boundaries between the teams right and
this is where you as an architect can
get involved with this you have a
front-end team the front-end team a
building code that plugs into an API
server sit with them at the beginning
and say right what we gotta do here it's
gonna fake up some API responses so you
can start work and then the other side
you get other the back-end dev team and
you say right I'm gonna help you build
the specifications the test suite for
your API and then you can go away and
build the client that satisfies those
requirements that's how you communicate
the designs you create the data and you
create the tests you work with them on
this and then you let them go and build
the actual code and then you can plug
these two pieces into each other and as
an architect that's where you look at
what's going on in the system and look
at the traffic are you seeing the data
structures that you expected to see is
the latency and the throughput and the
volume of traffic the kind of things you
were expecting to see one of the
questions that comes up often is should
architects still code yes absolutely yes
because if you stop coding your hair
goes pointy and they take away all your
def leppard t-shirts but don't work on
production systems because what will
happen is you'll have a good idea about
how to improve the architecture and
sooner or later you will give in to the
temptation and you'll be like I don't
want to update the diagrams and have a
meeting I'll just I'll just do it and
then the team will go what the hell have
you done and you're like it's better now
and they're like okay and the first time
they'll be like and the second time
they'll be like alright fine you do it
and you'll become the bottleneck again
and suddenly you'll be you know the
architecture is falling by the wayside
the team will be like well you keep
changing things so this is your problem
now we're not working with it anymore
but you have to keep a handle you have
to keep coding otherwise it's really
difficult one to just you know keep your
tools sharp keep up to date with what's
going on in software - it's a great way
of establishing credibility and good
working relationships best way I've
found to do this is the architect builds
the monitoring systems you pick people
on the teams you like right I want to
take your API what it's doing and I want
to show that traffic on a big screen on
the wall of the office with you know red
and green lights and all this kind of
stuff let's pair together on building
that thing so you as a coder get enough
of an ins
right into how that system works but
you're not responsible for anything
that's actually going into production in
a customer-facing system you're building
the stuff that runs on the wall and one
it gives you a sense of ownership you
know you're like hey this is cool I got
some life code in there too you get a
chance to collaborate with people kind
of learn from them share some advice and
wisdom most architects were pretty good
developers before they started
specializing in architecture there's
value in that stuff but just don't let
yourself become the bottleneck the other
thing that you can do a lot of the time
particularly when you you make a
decision say to go and use er
off-the-shelf service or host something
somewhere or integrate with a payment
provider as a business decision it makes
a lot of sense because these things work
but for developers on the team often
that experience sucks because they have
these these nasty api's with signed xml
crypto signatures and weird sand boxes
and stuff and the developers don't see
the business value I had a real case a
couple years ago where we ported a whole
bunch of stuff across from in-house
systems to Microsoft Dynamics and
Dynamics as a developer it has some
interesting capabilities but there was a
lot of things about it which are quite
difficult to work with and you know the
team was getting a bit downtrodden I
wonder I said then one day do you
remember last year every Monday morning
somebody would spend two hours pulling
mailing lists out of the database so
that the marketing team could send the
weekly newsletter and they all went yeah
and I went have you noticed we don't do
that anymore
and they all went oh yeah because you
lose sight of this stuff when the
business problem gets solved the
developers very rarely see the solution
your job as an architect is to go look
no remember that nasty thing we used to
do we don't do that anymore this is why
you know communicate the value that is
being created through these decisions
pair with the other developers on your
team build dashboards build monitoring
systems look at the network traffic
don't make yourself a bottleneck all of
these kinds of things are the
collaboration patterns that you can use
to build high functioning teams to allow
these behaviors to emerge to respond to
change over following a plan you have
the plan but you're not married to it if
the plan is wrong you make a better plan
and all of this stuff there is this
classic xkcd cartoon how to write
good code you know and you can okay well
we got to do things right or fast if you
do it fast does it work yet no no no no
almost but it's a massive clutches and
spaghetti code throw it out and start
over otherwise you do it right code it
well are you done no and the
requirements have changed do you know
how you get good code good code happens
when good developers look at code and go
I can make this better and they do and
almost everything that we talked about
at events like this about how to build
better systems the frameworks unit
testing integration testing architecture
what we are trying to do is empower that
developer to feel confident that they
can try out their idea for improving it
architecture is the stuff that is
expensive to change you get it right the
things will be cheaper to change those
little ideas little refinements someone
can open a piece of code and go I think
I can refactor this to make this work
better make this fit better buy good
architecture empowers people to do this
whole teams to do this over years and
years and years like I said it's hard to
validate you come back five years later
and you see whether it's working or not
if it isn't gently steering around a
little bit but like everything else it's
about giving good developers the ability
to look at a piece of code make it
better ship it and know that they
haven't broken anything by doing that
thank you
[Applause]